la consommation de crevettes a explosé
ces dernières années depuis le mois de
janvier et en a vendu environ 45000
kilos de crevettes devant un mur de
frigo de crevettes difficile de choisir
il y à des produits de toutes les sortes
des variétés de crevettes blanche tigre
et d'argentine nordique cuite cru
décortiqué ou non les crevettes sont
parmi les cinq meilleurs vendeurs dans
l'eau poissonnerie j'imagine que c'est
quelque chose qui peut être comparé à un
peu dans les supermarchés dans les
autres poissonnerie un aliment populaire
avec des bons nutriments mais qui peut
contenir des quantités non négligeables
de sodium dans la cuisine de l'institut
sur la nutrition et les aliments
fonctionnels
nous rencontrons la nutritionniste
louise corps nous c'est vrai que les
crevettes on se dit bon c'est un aliment
nature il doit pas avoir tâté de viol ou
athée et la valeur nutritive doit être
dans son ensemble assez intéressant mais
quand je me suis mis à vraiment regarder
de près les étiquettes nutritionnelles
effectivement on ne j'ai eu de très
grandes surprises
la teneur en sodium entre août et
vraiment très élevé le on a 6 150 mg de
sodium pour 100 g donc messi comparé
avec d'autres produits par exemple je
regarde ici qui sont aussi un autre sac
de crevettes qui a écouté le niveau de
sodium à l'intérieur est différent on
parle de 150 mg pour 100 g il peut avoir
des variations on voit en fait que pour
un même une même marque on pourrait
avoir le produit qui passe de 10 à 30%
alors que c'est une crevette tout simple
que pas eu d'assaisonnement donc cette
différence là vraiment aller haut niveau
provenant du traitement qui est
appliquée à la crevette la crevette est
un aliment qui subit une transformation
à la base selon la variété
elle peut
plus ou moins de sodium mais lors de la
transformation
on ajoute des additifs qui peuvent
modifier la valeur nutritive le sel dans
le rôle pour prévenir la dégradation de
la crevette notamment parce que le sel
sony aux molécules d'eau et le fait
d'être lié à la molécule d'eau ça la
rend moins disponible c'est tout là pour
la croissance des micro-organismes donc
des bactéries qui pourraient avoir des
effets néfastes ou d'altération sur
l'aliment selon l'agencé canadienne
d'inspection des aliments
plusieurs autres additifs sont autorisés
dans des limites bien spécifié sauf que
le sel une des premières étapes dans la
préparation de la crevette c'est de
faire un trempage dans une solution de
tripoli phosphates de sodium instinct
agents technologique qui permet de
gonfler la chaire donc de la crevette et
ça permet ensuite de plus facilement
décortiquer la crever lorsque la
crevette et le transforme et qu'elle a
suivi des étapes de lavage à la fin on
doit ajouter aussi du sel donc c'est une
étape de saumur âge puis le ciel vous
permettent de rehausser les saveurs
l'échantillonnage de crevettes analysés
par l'épicerie contient entre 45 et 8
140 mg de sodium par portion de 100 g
il faut donc bien regardé le tableau de
la valeur nutritive
mais le problème c'est que plusieurs
produits sont vendus sans étiquette ou
en vrac c'est pas une obligation du
détaillant de nous mettre la valeur ne
traiter d'un tableau de valeur nutritive
sur les aliments vendus en vrac une des
façons mais c'est pas toujours postés
c'est d'aller voir le poissonnier
vie dans sa caisse en arrière c'est bien
des difficultés donc c'est possible
d'avoir cette information là mais comme
je vous dis ça dépend de la bonne
volonté du poissonnier de nous fournir
l'information il ya ce tract de
crevettes là si je regarde y'a aucune
valeur nutritive en fait qu'est-ce que
ça moi je peux savoir ce que j'achèterai
des contraintes comme jeudi au niveau
des sacs qui rentrent ici donc c'est
d'être au des gros volumes donc puis on
peut pas refaire des étiquettes de
valeur nutritive par contre
l'information est toujours pas
disponibles auprès d'un poissonnier qui
lui peut aller se référer aux sacs
d'origine cuisine informer sur les
quantités de sodium
nous nous sommes rendus dans l'entrepôt
d'un grand distributeur de poissons et
de fruits de mer pour voir les sacs
d'origine mohamed est le responsable du
contrôle de la qualité et des stickers
très important pour nous et s'il ya
juste la crevette et du cèdre vos
étiquettes ne donnent tous les
ingrédients ray valeur nutritive
l'usiné a été préparé le poids on peut
tracer ce qu'on avons déjà chez keyyo la
saison des questions on répond à notre
clientèle une traçabilité importante
pour le distributeur mais aussi pour le
consommateur en vérifiant le tableau de
la valeur nutritive
on se rend compte par exemple le psy
crevettes contient 8 140 mg de sodium
soit 35 % de l'apport recommandé par
jour c'est sûr que si on garde en tête
un canadien sur quatre est hypertendu et
que le sodium c'est un des facteur
principal au niveau de l'hypertension
c'est sûr que ce serait une information
qui serait intéressante qui permettrait
de faire des choix plus éclairés et
aussi peut-être de faire prendre
conscience aux gens que c'est une source
importante de sodium
dans tous les lieux visités nous avons
réussi à obtenir l'information et suite
à nos questions métro affirme que
dorénavant les valeurs nutritives pour
les crevettes surgelées vendus en vrac
seront affichés l'apport élevé en sodium
pourrait faire augmenter la rigidité des
vaisseaux sanguins
même si on souffre pas d'hypertension on
peut quand même avoir des conséquences à
avoir une alimentation trop riche en
sodium
il faut donc rechercher des produits qui
contiennent un maximum de 15 % de
l'apport quotidien recommandé en sodium
juste avec 5,6 est creux virtonais à 400
500 600 700 mg de sodium
donc si souvent on se limite pas à se
trouver on en mange 12
c'est notre force on est souvent plus
grosse que 6e crevettes pour mettre la
petite chose qui va avec la sauce à
cocktail qui est déjà très salée et
qu'on plus ramassé avec un 1000 mg le mg
là c'est la moitié de la quantité de
sodium qu'on devrait consommer
quotidiennement alors c'est pas
négligeable
c'est certain que la crevette un
substitut pour la viande on le dit c'est
intéressant quand même ça veut contenir
des oméga-3 ça va conduire des protéines
donc c'est quand même un bon choix
étant donné que c'est sale et que et il
ya des limitations quand même sa
consommation
ça serait quelque chose qu'on pourrait
prendre de façon occasionnelle
puis la cuisine et simplement selon
karine tout simplement la faire sauter
avec du jus de citron de l'huile ajouter
des herbes des épices façon à la roma
teasé on peut aussi la déguster tout
simplement nature c'est aussi beau
[Musique]
à